let's talk about Sam cedar okay earlier
in the week I told you that friend of
the show Sam cedar a host of the
majority majority report the voice of
multiple characters on the smash TV
series Bob's Burgers formerly of air
America radio etc etc he was targeted by
this alt-right dude named Mike Tsarevich
for a tweet that he sent a satirical
tweet in the context of slamming those
who are defending the a sexual assault
escapades of movie director Roman
Polanski
he sent a satirical tweet uh eight years
ago which said something along the lines
of if my daughter were ever raped I hope
it would be by a truly talented man with
a great sense of meson son meson sin and
and I'm sort of paraphrasing the tweet
an entire campaign to get Sam fired as
an MSNBC contributor started as a result
of Mike Serna bitch's tweet about this a
campaign to get Sam's advertisers to
pull advertising dollars off of his show
the majority report started and it
appeared as though it had worked MSNBC
announced a few days ago they were
pulling Sam off the air and that they
would not be renewing his contract he
wasn't scheduled to appear until the end
of the contract he would not appear and
his contract would not be renewed and I
pointed out the sickening hypocrisy and
double standard of these alt writers who
claim to be against outraged culture
they claim to be against those who just
can't understand that you can joke about
things and you're not necessarily a bad
person and they claim to be totally
outraged about what is obviously a
satirical joke from eight years ago
however MSNBC has done the right thing
and they are now going to renew their
contract with Sam cedar they are not
going to be severing ties with him
because they figured it out and Sam
commented on this for the for the
intercept he had a statement where he
said I appreciate MSNBC's thoughtful
reconsideration and willingness to
understand the cynical motives of those
who intentionally misrepresented my
tweet for their own toxic political
purposes
we are experiencing an important and
long overdue moment of empowerment for
the victims of sexual assault and of
reckoning for their perpetrators I'm
proud that MSNBC and its staff have set
a clear example of the need to get it
right this is the right decision and to
be perfectly clear Sam was not nor have
I ever heard Sam diminish the
seriousness of sexual assault
allegations of the actions committed by
sexual assaulters abusers and rapists
there was nothing here that was an
actual defense of Roman Polanski in any
way quite frankly none of what Sam cedar
was being accused of having done was
accurate and this was an absolute and
utter bottom-feeding campaign that
appeared to have worked and fortunately
it didn't and you know what I think that
in the end this might end up being kind
of good for Sam because it's gotten him
a lot of attention yes and it has I
would assume although I haven't spoken
to him about this brought in a lot of
new paid subscribers for Sam who
understand the absurdity of this and in
the end he's still gonna be back on
MSNBC and you know MSNBC they have to do
their due diligence the next time around
didn't Phil Griffin say that yeah we
messed up on this one he is on record in
an intercept article about this saying
we got this one wrong but we made it
right or something along those lines so
hey it happened and a lot of it has to
do with the audience's of Sam's show and
of other progressive shows who heard
about this story and activated around it
and you know what everything came
together and this is the right decision
and the best part is they failed these
fake outrage alt-right campaigns that
often are successful it failed miserably
because Sam didn't actually say what it
is that they accuse him of having said
which is a defense of Roman Polanski and
the minimizing of actual sexual assault
didn't happen it's satire everyone knows
the absolute and total satire and this
is being discussed on our david pakman
show subreddit which you can find at
david pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is made possible in part by Blue
Sky binaries blockchain Academy
blockchain the technology on which
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies can be
many people not aware of both the power
and the risks that are carried by
blockchain technology I've only started
to get into this a little bit buying a
little bit of Bitcoin here and their
dollar cost averaging but a lot of
people myself included believe that
blockchain technology is just too
complicated to understand but the truth
is it doesn't have to be that way the
blue sky binary blockchain Academy from
leading financial education firm blue
sky binary explains how blockchain works
and it can work in addition to existing
knowledge that you have about blockchain
it's for both beginners and active
cryptocurrency users alike with the
course students are taken through a
series of topics which ultimately will
deliver a very solid understanding of
how blockchain works and helps students
realize the potential future uses of
blockchain technology we've talked about
this in the pharmaceutical world we've
talked about this in the IT security
world many many possibilities for
blockchain and the course includes video
on-demand online tests access to a
community of traders and blockchain
enthusiasts and at blue sky binary.com /
David you can register to get a free
three-day trial which includes access to
the first module of the course for you
to evaluate the overall quality and
decide if you want to stick with it get
a free three-day trial at blue sky
binary.com / David